Hello, welcome.
It is April 9th, 2026
and we're in active inference model
stream 007.3
on pymdp 1.0, the JAX first release of
pymdp
with Connor Hines and other guests. So,
we will be hearing about pymdp release
and discussing some topics about
applications of active inference and the
package. So, thank you to Connor and all
the developers for their work. And
Connor to you, thank you.
Cool. Yeah, thanks a lot, Daniel.
Um yeah, happy to be with you all.
Thanks for attending.
Uh yeah, so I'm really excited to share
this release with you. Um this is
the 100 release of pymdp. Um this is an
active inference package
that we first started working on back in
2019 and it's matured and changed a lot
over the years.
So, this um talk uh this presentation is
about the 100 release, which is an
upgrade from the last release, which I
think was
almost 3 years ago or maybe a little
over than 3 years ago.
Um and the kind of biggest headline
change to highlight here is the fact
that we rewrote the entire back end of
pymdp in JAX.
Um so, now it's a kind of a JAX first,
JAX only package.
And because [clears throat] of that
rewrite
and motivating that rewrite
we have a bunch of new uh capabilities
uh for active inference agents in in
discrete state spaces. So, first of all,
just because it's in JAX, it's really
trivial to now put everything on GPUs
and TPUs.
Um that's just comes from having
everything in JAX. So, now you can run,
you know, whole groups, hundreds,
thousands of active inference agents uh
paralyzed on GPUs. You're only
constrained basically by your hardware
memory, whether it's GPU or TPU.
Um also, because it's in JAX, which is
natively fully differentiable, you can
kind of hook up arbitrary differentiable
modules to the front end or the back end
or in the middle of any pymdp agent. So,
that means you can pass gradients
through the whole system and do like
end-to-end learning sort of uh
workflows, which is cool.
Um and you know, it it it I would say um
significantly increases the
sort of things that you can do with
discrete pymdp agents. So, you can
imagine hooking up a pymdp agent to say
images or audio or more high-dimensional
uh input data than normally you couldn't
because of the kind of poor scaling
features you get with fully uh discrete
categorical inputs.
Um another big uh benefit of JAX is the
just-in-time compilation uh feature. So,
that allows you to basically run things
much faster uh cuz the kind of com-
computation graph of the full active
inference process is being compiled
ahead of time. And then you can actually
just execute that in this lower uh
accelerated linear algebra language XLA
that that JAX kind of writes and
dispatches to. So, um what that means in
practice is that now pymdp can be used
like a lot of these other JAX-based RL
frameworks where you can get really high
throughput simulations on arbitrary
JAX-based reinforcement learning
environments.
Um so, you can kind of JIT or
just-in-time compile the full
agent-environment loop and that allows
you to run things like orders of
magnitude than you would be able to in
the old um
un-JITed NumPy back end.
And so, beside all those I kind of just
core capabilities that are unlocked by
putting everything in JAX, there's also
just loads of new features.
Um so, new kind of algorithms that have
been developed in the last couple years
in the active inference community, like
sophisticated inference, inductive
inference,
um those are all now uh in integrated
into the new pymdp. So, those just allow
you uh to have smarter agents in the
end. So, you're actually using better
planning algorithms, better inference
algorithms.
Um another nice thing and actually this
is what originally motivated me and
Dimitri Markovik, who's on this call, I
believe.
What originally motivated us to write
the JAX back end, this was like, I think
going back to 2022 even, was the ability
to fit pymdp models or or active
inference pomdps to experimental data
from from, for instance, experimental
um psychology or or uh cognitive uh
computational neuroscience sort of
settings where you're actually measuring
the behavior of people as they perform
some task.
Um one of the things that's that many
people in the kind of more experimental
applied field of active inference do is
they want to fit the parameters of pomdp
models to data. So, it's basically like
kind of creating a uh synthetic active
inference agent that behaves like your
experimental participants. And um now
that everything is in JAX, you can
actually do that very efficiently using
uh NumPyro, using basically there's
there's other third-party JAX-based
probabilistic programming software like
NumPyro that allows you to um use
any of those variational or
sampling-based inference algorithms to
fit the parameters of pomdps to data.
So, this has been um really nicely
enabled by a package that Dimitri
Markovik wrote called
uh PyBaFit, which is a a package that
allows you to fit different models of
behavior to experimental data with both
NumPyro and Pyro, which is torch-based
back ends. So, pymdp now integrates with
PyBaFit, so you can fit uh
pomdp models to data really easily and
very quickly as well because uh NumPyro
is highly optimized and NumPyro is kind
of the JAX back end of PyBaFit.
Um there's a bunch of other things, so
I'll get into those with the slides. But
also, I just want to um kind of flag, as
you did Daniel at the beginning of this,
that this I'm I'm kind of a mouthpiece
for a larger team of people that have
been working on this for three, four
years uh that this this back end. So,
although I've done a lot of the work
maintaining and developing it, I do want
just everyone to, as you listen to this,
to know that what went into this was
like many, many man-hours, lots of
blood, sweat, and tears of many people.
So, I'm just kind of the the messenger
here.
But I'm happy and proud to to be showing
this to all of you.
Um so, yeah, as I mentioned, the back
end upgrade, uh the the accelerator
friendliness of it is one of the biggest
advantages.
So, if you really want to run very large
generative models or you want to run
them very quickly or you want to run
many generative models in parallel,
the best way to do that with JAX pymdp
is now on GPU or TPU. You can still get
quite good throughput and um speed on
CPU as well cuz JAX is just natively
fast because of the JIT thing. But if
you really want to crank like fitting uh
or running tens of thousands of active
inference agents in parallel, then you
can throw all your normal pymdp code
onto um a a Nvidia GPU accelerated
device and then you can just put all
your and then you'll just see huge gains
in throughput because of that, which is
really nice.
So, yeah.
Another big aspect of this is this is
both because of JAX and the way that
we've restructured the code is that
everything is now uh natively and
trivially parallelized. So, every
parameter tensor, every agent, every um
set of beliefs or actions or
observations now has an implicit leading
dimension. So, you can always basically
just arbitrarily stack observations,
agents, beliefs um in parallel. And so,
all the methods of the seemingly single
agent class are actually under the hood
broadcasted uh along this leading
dimension. So, it means you can
basically run
like the difference between running one
and 10,000 agents is just a matter of
one batch size parameter. Um so, this
makes it really nice for high-throughput
experimentation. Say you want to try
uh a batch of a thousand agents, 500 on
one environmental configuration and
another 500 on another, like two say
experimental configurations or they
maybe have different generative models
or different hyperparameter
configurations. That's really trivial to
do with just one instance of this agent
class, which is the main like entry
point and API for pymdp.
Um as I also mentioned, the JIT
compilation of the full
agent-environment interaction is
incredibly powerful. So, this does
require that your environment be
JITable, so it needs to be something
that you can pass into uh JAX
operations. So, that puts certain
constraints on on the sort of
computations happening inside the
environment. But once you have a
JAX-friendly environment, and if you go
on GitHub, there's loads of now uh
JAX-friendly RL environmental
simulators, like Gym Nax, Jumanji,
Navix, those are a few examples,
then you can just JIT the entire or
just-in-time compile the entire active
inference inference and planning and
action loop together with the
environmental step.
And then that whole thing can run super,
super fast. I mean, I'll show you some
figures later to just kind of
demonstrate the the speed gain.
And then finally, uh the
differentiability aspect. So, I kind of
mentioned this before, but you can
arbitrarily tie together differentiable
modules with pymdp agents and uh and
use gradients however you want. You
could freeze the encoder, you could
define the variational free energy or
expected free energy at the agent level
and then backpropagate that to the
encoder or decoder or whatever you want.
So, I think that native
differentiability of JAX, and we
specifically tested all the methods of
the agent class to make sure they're
differentiable and they pass like valid
finite gradients, that enables a lot of
different new creative um ways to to
generate uh pymdp agents.
Um so, yeah, because of the JAX back
end, there are do new constraints on the
way that you write code. So, there's a
lot of data structures that have changed
and a lot of kind of control flow
primitives that have changed like the
way you do for loops, the way that you
write agent environment loops has has
changed a bit. So, um
the biggest change I would say, I mean,
yeah, I'll go through all of them cuz
it's hard to like rank which one's the
biggest, but one of the big changes is
the way that we store uh
ragged arrays. So, before a ragged array
is basically arrays where the the sub
elements have different dimensions.
So, before we're using something called
an an uh NumPy object array, which is
kind of just like a list of arrays,
except that you can um you could in
theory create higher dimensional
versions like an array of of differently
shaped arrays.
So, to make uh that convention
compatible with JAX's uh
operations, which assume basically
everything is a PyTree, which is just a
sort of collection or or a data
structure with leaves at the end of the
day,
uh we made everything into
um lists, lists of JAX arrays. So, now
instead of NumPy object arrays, you just
have lists of arrays, and that's the
kind of the base data structure
uh
that that we store say
uh different posterior marginals. So, if
you have marginal distributions over
different hidden latent variables have
different lengths, different support uh
cardinalities, then you would store
those each as a different entry in a
list of of arrays. And these arrays
themselves, of course, are are JAX
arrays now. So, JAX has a sub library of
NumPy.
And that's the kind of um and it has
like the same semantics as an API as
as classic NumPy does.
And the other big thing is the using use
of explicit control of randomness
through these PRNG keys. So,
typically in NumPy, you'll you'll kind
of set randomness globally or at least
outside of particular operations. Like
you might have a script local seed or
like a repo or global um execution
runtime global seed. In JAX, you
actually have to pass seeds and keys all
all the way through every computation
that requires randomness.
So, that means most of the classic
functions that in involve randomness
like sampling from action, sampling
observations, all those things you now
have to actually pass a PRNG key into
the relevant function. So, it adds a
little bit of API overhead in the sense
that you're now passing in a new
argument all these functions, but the
nice thing is it it's really nice for
controlling reproducibility at different
parts in in a in a computation graph.
So, if you want to inject stochasticity
into just one part of an agent
environment loop, like just into the
action sampling or just into the
observation sampling, or if there's some
kind of stochasticity happening in the
inference, then you can kind of control
that along the way using these JAX uh
PRNG keys. Cuz the key point to to state
here is that every time you pass one of
these keys into a stochastic function,
the output will be the same if the key
is the same cuz it's just a
uh way of seeding um reproducibly the
randomness.
Another big um kind of API and like
programming philosophy shift is the fact
that now PyMDP is a lot more functional.
So, because it's JAX, there's a lot of
things you can't do. Like mutability is
um is different. There's really no uh
in-place operations and mutability of
data structures. What you actually have
to do is more write things as changes or
um creating instantiating new copies of
arrays.
So, there's no more in-place updates.
You can use there's conventions in JAX
like the   index set value
notation.
And uh and there's also constraints on
um having static shape and dtype of
input inputs to functions that are
just-in-time compiled. So, it means that
if you're say doing a uh a for loop in
JAX and you want to use the scan uh
primitive, which is a way to do really
fast just-in-time compiled for loops, it
means that you need to make sure that
all the inputs and outputs say if it's
the updates to a posterior belief that
they have the same shape and dtype. So,
often times you as a user do will not
have to worry about this at all because
it's all handled by the agent class, but
if you're ever like creating PyMDP
agents on your own, these are like new
constraints that you have to be aware
of. And basically any JAX-based uh
software has this these sorts of
constraints. But they they take a little
bit of getting used to, but they're
they're not honestly too hard to to
master.
And then as I also men- mentioned, old
uh NumPy kind of assumed single agent um
semantics everywhere. So, the agent
class really represented one agent, but
now the agent class in the JAX backend
na- uh naturally assumes that you can
always basically add
arbitrarily numbers of agents in in into
your single agent parameter tensor. So,
instead of having one A or B or C or D
tensor, you can just expand the leading
dimension and really run 50 different
agents in parallel. The only constraints
there is that you have to make sure that
all the generative models of those
agents have the same dimension so that
you can stack the parameter tensors
um vertically onto each other.
Um
Yeah, so what else?
Yeah, I guess
a big a big change is the um the the way
we do things like for loops. For
instance, instead of writing a a classic
Python for loop, you can use this
lax.scan notation. So, this is basically
a way of of JAX pre-compiling all the
steps of a for loop in advance given
that it knows like the the start and end
of the loop, and then as executing it
really quickly. Um also parallelization
is enabled by things like vmap. So, vmap
is vectorized map, and that's how this
vmap operator is how we
basically take methods that act on
single agent parameters and just
very trivially broadcast them across
multiple um agents, observations,
actions, or whatever. We're basically
just defining a bunch of methods that
operate on single agent
information, and then we broadcast using
vmap across multiple agents. So, that's
why it's very trivial in JAX once you've
written a function that operates say on
one row or one column of an array to
just trivially vmap it without having to
write your own custom broadcasting
semantics.
And of course, the biggest one is
probably JIT, the just-in-time
compilation. As I'll show in a bit,
JITing operations is like one of the
biggest ways to it's it is the biggest
way to increase throughput and speed
um in in in any JAX-based computation.
So, there's a little bit of overhead
time, very little relatively, to
actually compile the program in advance.
So, you always like JIT the program,
there's a warm-up time in actually
computing pre-computing that XLA
computation graph, and then once you
execute execute the JITed function, it's
incredibly fast. And it has a couple
constraints like you need to know the um
input
types of the arrays, the input shapes of
the arrays, and also the
types and shapes of the output arrays.
So, those are the constraints on like
JITed functions. That's more just like
kind of JAX 101, but these um properties
of JAX have now propagated forward into
PyMDP.
Um so, [clears throat] yeah, now I'll
give a just a quick example. So, in
old-style PyMDP, you might have a couple
of lines like this.
Don't know if you can see my cursor, but
on the left I'm highlighting this agent
um construction where you pass in some
AB
arrays. You might pass in some here
single modality trivial observation. You
do some state inference using that
observation using agent.infer_states.
You estimate the posterior over policies
and then the negative expected free
energy using infer_policies, and then
you sample an action. So, the nice thing
about this is very simple and clean.
Um and we've tried to make the the JAX
backend as little as little extra
complexity. We want to respect this
old-style like very
object-oriented API, but we're still
getting all the benefits of of JAX. So,
now in JAX,
in addition to just your A and B tensors
that you pass in, you can also pass in a
batch size.
So, if A and B, for instance, are just a
single agent parameter tensors, it'll
just broadcast this to be 10 different
agents all with the same A and B's. Or
you can pass in heterogeneous A's and
B's that have that leading dimension,
and then this will just basically this
can either be inferred or you can state
it declaratively to just basically tell
the agent class in advance, yeah,
there's 10 agents and they So, you can
look in the leading dimension of these
tensors to find the different models of
every agent.
Um the agent.infer_states now uh returns
a a QS variable. So, in the previous
um NumPy version, you could return QS,
but also QS was stored, which is the
posterior over hidden states. That was
stored internally on the agent. Now, the
posterior over hidden states is is
natively returned. That that's in line
with this whole functional philosophy of
JAX. So, there's no more posterior
belief variables stored on the agent
except for the parameters. The
parameters stay on the agent, but now
like the um
beliefs and actions get uh always
returned. So, the agent.infer_states
method acts more like a function, but we
still maintain the kind of method-like
API.
And so again, you pass in obs, and you
also pass in some kind of empirical
prior. So, this is very useful in
functional workflows where sometimes the
empirical prior will be something that's
stored on the agent. This is basically
the belief from the last time step, like
the D vector at the first time step of
inter- inference, or it can be something
that you're passing in from the outside,
for instance, like the last value of QS,
which is no longer available on the
agent because everything is functional
now.
Um and then infer_policies is basically
the same except now, again, because QS
is not stored on the agent, you actually
have to pass in the posterior belief
upon which the rollouts are going to be
based.
And also we've done some trivial things
like we renamed G to the negative EFE
just to be more explicit about that cuz
that was causing some confusion.
And then as I said before, you have to
be very um explicit about randomness
whenever you're doing something random.
So, for instance, when you're doing
action sampling, not only do you pass in
the posterior over policies, which again
was the return of agent.infer_policies,
but you also pass in random keys.
And these random keys can either differ
per agent, in which case you'll sample
random actions for every agent, or if
you want all the agents to use the exact
same random seed when they sample their
action, you could just use the same key
for all agents. But the point here is
that the random keys you have to pass
in, they have to have the same number of
elements as there are agents in your
batch. So, if you have 10 agents, then
you have to split the random key into 10
different keys, one for every agent.
Um so, that's really nice cuz then you
can basically control randomness
selectively across different agents,
uh either uniformly or you can break the
symmetry kind of in the in the agent
sampling.
Another really uh interesting and I
think semantically uh user-friendly
feature we added was this idea of the
model and distribution API. So, in these
um
in in this new kind of way of compiling
and building a model, you can actually
specify the whole graphical model using
a dict. So,
uh
basically the dict will will store
things like the names of the random
variables, like the observations, the
control states, and the hidden states.
And then within each of those um random
variable specific sub dicts, you'll have
a dict like the position observation
modality, which will have
its different elements, basically the
support of that categorical
distribution. The nice thing about all
these things is that they they just have
semantic labels, so it's no more like 1
2 3 4 and kind of arbitrary linear
indices into tensors, but all of these
variables actually can be associated
with semantic names that perhaps capture
some um specific constraints for your
task. So, this would be like
uh example of one of these model
description for a grid world where you
have some position observations that
correspond to like left, um
center left, center right, right. So,
this is like a 1D grid world. You could
have a move left or move right action.
And as you're writing these strings,
you're basically just assigning labels
to each of the kind of variables or
levels in the support of your
categorical distribution. So, once you
assemble this dict, which basically has
these high level observations, controls,
and state variables, then you can just
kind of pass that into this compile
model function, and it'll immediately
generate you a model which has fields
like A, B, C, D. And then what you can
do with that is you can actually index
semantically into those arrays using the
names of the modalities, like the
position observation modality, and then
within that modality index into
particular rows and columns of that A
matrix using the semantic labels of the
values. So, instead of doing some weird
nested indexing of like A01,2,3,
you're actually indexing with more um
semantically uh meaningful and
semantically like relatable uh terms.
So, for instance, this uh this line
right here, model.b_position,
is saying I want to look at the position
state factor, the the transitions
corresponding to the the position state
factor, and I want to look at what is
the probability of moving to the center
left given I'm currently in the left
uh position and I took action move
right.
So, it makes sense. If you're in the
left and you go closer to the center by
taking the move right action, that
probability is one. So, you can both
inspect, like query the generative
models, as well as set them um using
this sort of notation.
And then finally, once you've compiled
the model, you can just pass that model,
you basically unpack it with this double
uh asterisks notation cuz it's it's it's
a kind of a dict sort of structure. You
just unpack it, pass it into the agent
class, and then you will just create an
agent that has the A and B tensors um
that have been specified in this kind of
more semantic way. You still have to
fill out the probabilities in your
tensors. So, just by the uh providing
the description of what are the elements
of the tensors, what random variables
drive what other variables, you haven't
actually specified what those
probabilities are. So, you still have to
go in and build the generative model
that way, but at least you can establish
the connectivity and the names of all
the variables in your model just through
this kind of more string-based
interface.
Okay, yes. So, now that um I've kind of
introduced what the main features are of
the new JAX backend,
um there's still a a bit on model
fitting I want to get to, but I want to
just show some benchmarks on actually
um what the new JAX
backend buys you. So, here I just took a
kind of standard generative model. This
is the epistemic huge chaining task, so
it's kind of like a version of the
classic T maze that's a little bit more
temporally deep and it has multiple
cues.
So, just I just fixed the generative
model, um and then I
ran different backends of PyMDP for
different numbers of agents.
And I compared it, like so, the legacy
NumPy version, the JAX um version on
both CPU and GPU, and then I also
compared it to C++ active inference,
which is a a really optimized C++ based
active inference implementation that
came out a couple years ago, and which
showed really uh competitive I mean,
just superior results to NumPy uh PyMDP
at the time, which was incredibly slow.
So, I just wanted to like reproduce
those results and then also compare them
to um JAX.
So, just like quick before I get into
them, just quick details on the
epistemic huge chaining. These rollouts
were 12 steps, so pre- pretty small, so
you're not actually running into the
benefits of JITing the rollout at this
stage.
Um policy length four, still quite
small. The main thing here I wanted to
get out was the parallelization benefits
you get from running multiple agents, so
up to 512 agents.
And the NumPy legacy, I only ran up to
128 agents cuz it was just getting too
slow if you if you push it. So,
basically what you can see is you get
really high throughput that gets even
better on A100 GPU. I mean, running 512
of these small agents on the A100 is not
even getting close to the to the maximum
throughput you can get. So, I don't
exactly know what this number is and cuz
I it's somewhere between 10K and 100K,
but the point but on this logarithmic
scale, but it's incredibly incredibly
fast.
JAX, [snorts] even on the CPU, this is
Cython line, is also incredibly high
throughput. So, that Y axis I should
mention is agent steps per second. So,
this is like a classic measure of
throughput, it's like how many agent
steps are you performing for per second.
And the big throughput gain here is
because we're running multiple agents in
parallel. So, that's going to factor in
to the to the throughput. Basically, the
number of agent steps is going to scale
proportionally to the number of agents.
Um and then you have CPP AIF, which is
actually incredibly fast as well,
especially compared to the
um legacy
uh PyMDP, and you can see that if you
use 12 threads, so I think this supports
up to 24 threads. I guess it just
depends on how many threads you have in
your CPU, you can get really high
throughput, but it's still not as fast
as JAX, and I think that's just because
um CPP AIF also doesn't natively batch
across multiple agents. So, you can't
really parallelize effectively across
hundreds of agents. I think there's
still natively some sort of for- I mean,
there would have to be some sort of for
loop because the the parameter um
tensors are not don't have a leading
batch dimension. Where you get really
high throughput just by V-mapping over
that leading dimension in JAX.
Um [clears throat] so, another uh
kind of metric to look at is scaling in
the number of policies. So, once you
increase the horizon, say of your
planning problem, a classic issue with
this discrete time uh exhaustive tree
search active inference is that you get
really bad scaling in the number of
policies. So,
I'm still using native tree search here.
I haven't actually in- improved the
algorithm for doing tree search. I'm
still doing an exhaustive search over
very large number of policies,
but at least the the ability to run that
algorithmically still expensive tree
search, the cost of that is much lower
now with JAX. So, now on this Y axis,
we're just showing the raw runtime in
milliseconds, so lower is going to be a
better score.
And again, comparing NumPy legacy in
orange, the two types of C++ active
inference in one thread in purple, 12
threads in pink, and then the two
backends for JAX um PyMDP.
So, with 100 JAX PyMDP on on M2 on this
MacBook that I'm on right now, you get
increasing runtime just like all of the
rest in the number of policies, but it's
it's clearly much um
lower, absolutely. But the scaling
property is still pretty much the same.
It eventually gets kind of linear in the
number of policies.
On the GPU, it's much longer before you
start hitting this linear increase, and
that's because on with this much memory
on an A100 GPU, you're V-mapping over
policies, and you're really not hitting
kind of the hardware limits at that
level. So, once you start going to very
um many policies, and these are long
policies, too, of length 24, you'll
start getting you'll start
bottom-necking on memory and stuff like
that, and you'll start getting uh linear
increases in runtime. But absolutely
speaking, you're still running 16,384
policies in less than 50 milliseconds on
on the GPU. So, that's really nice. And
that's just because we're V-mapping. So,
we're not writing any fancy extra math
to deal with like parallelized
computation of uh policy posteriors.
We're just writing a single function
that evaluates the expected free energy
of one policy, and we've just written
that function in a way so that you can
V-map it trivially over, say, 16,000
policies.
So, that's just a really nice thing you
get out of the box by switching to this
uh JAX backend.
And then finally, I want to show some
results on time horizon scaling. So,
um this is basically showing the the
effect of using this rollout function
where you're kind of getting the entire
agent environment loop.
So, what's interesting here is if you
just look at
normal JAX,
um
increasing time horizon on the x-axis
measuring throughput, so agent steps per
second on on the y-axis.
If you just do a native JAX for loop
with no getting, none of that, it's
actually slower than NumPy. So, that
that just goes to show you really have
to get if you want to use JAX. Um and
this is So, this is measuring basically
the whole agent inference, um planning,
and action, and the environmental step
all in one for loop. That actually ends
up being slower than NumPy. I think if
you pushed the size of the generative
model, the batch size, of course,
because NumPy would have to for loop,
and then the number of policies, this
orange would actually
hop ahead of the Or sorry, the purple
would go ahead of of the orange in terms
of throughput. But for this small kind
of um
somewhat reasonable generative model
that you would might imagine someone's
using in like a pedagogical or research
context, JAX is actually going to be
slower.
Uh just the native for loop. However,
once you start getting things, uh
immediately the JAX
uh pops ahead. And this is all on CPU,
by the way. This is not on GPU.
So, the throughput is like basically
more than It's probably what 2,000
2,000 steps per second for just JIT
stepping. Uh so, just getting the full
step function and then running that
JITted step function in a for loop. And
then you get even better throughput if
you then JIT the entire agent
environment loop. So, the difference
basically between this green and the
yellow is whether we're getting the
entire agent environment interaction or
we're just getting the single step time
step function, which is just the agent
taking one active inference step and
then the environment taking one sampling
an observation given the action step.
So, there's already a difference there,
but it's actually not that big. But
then, once you start moving it to very
big time horizons and you put it on on a
a GPU, you're actually really taking
advantage of of the high throughput on a
GPU.
And also the fact that you're minimizing
dispatch between the CPU host and the
the GPU, the hardware that you're
running it on, that's when you really
start seeing the difference between
getting the full agent environment cycle
and um just doing a a Pythonic for loop
of the JITted step function. So, when
you have a really long time horizon, so
that imagine like a really long um agent
environment interaction,
then you start getting really, really
high throughput on a GPU. And this is
also batch size equals one. So, the
difference would be even greater if we
say we're running 1,000 agents in
parallel. But even for a single agent,
you can see that at a time horizon of
2,048, we're getting 3,400
agent steps per second. So, that's like
a really, really fast latency. Um you
can run loads of experiments this way.
Okay, so that's kind of the the
benchmarks and the sort of acceleration
that you just trivially get from putting
everything on JAX and V-mapping
everywhere.
And now I just want to highlight some of
the new planning and inference
algorithms.
So, um I think the biggest thing to
highlight here is the sophisticated
inference um algorithm. So, this is
uh basically a way to This is based on a
paper that came out in 2021. So,
sophisticated inference is a way to kind
of just do more intelligent planning.
Um
it actually, from an algorithmic
perspective, has worse scaling than the
original tree tree search-based active
inference cuz in sophisticated
inference, you're branching on both
future states
and future actions and future
observations. So, the thing about
sophisticated inference is what it
simulates is an agent taking an action,
getting a
a possible imagined observation given
that action, and then updating its
belief given that observation, and then
planning from that new belief state at
this imagined forward point in time. So,
you have to branch on the possible
observations you might see at each time
step in the future and then branch on
the actions you might take in the
future. So, from a pure algorithmic
perspective, it's actually a really bad
scaling algorithm in time horizon
because of this exponential explosion.
But there's a bunch of tricks you can
use to basically make the actual search
size of the search tree much, much
smaller. So, you can basically prune off
branches of the search tree based on the
expected um expected free energy that
you might get down one branch. And so,
we have a highly optimized JIT and JAX
compatible version of sophisticated
inference now in PyMDP. Um this was
mainly the work of Tim Ver Balen and
Riddhi Pitliya. Um so, they did a really
good job in in implementing that and
demoing it. So, just wanted to shout
that out cuz I think that's one of the
most powerful things about this new
release is the use
of sophisticated inference. Um there's a
lot of cases where you get demonstrably
better planning because of sophisticated
inference. The fact that you can
counterfactually update your or like
imagine how your beliefs would update in
light of new evidence allows you to make
much better informed decisions about
where to go next. So, one of the biggest
things I think about sophisticated
inference that's really attractive is
its ability to make information gain
task relevant. So, one of the problems
with classic
active inference is that there's this
intrinsic curiosity drive, so agents
will get distracted with parts of the
world that just have high information
gain. With sophisticated inference,
there will only be branches of the
search tree that are kind of upweighted
in terms of probability based on if that
resolved uncertainty then allows you to
further minimize expected free energy.
So, say if there's some hidden structure
in the world that upon discovering it
then allows you to maximize utility,
then that search tree will be or that
path in your search tree will be
preferred relative to one that's just
discovering hidden structure in the
world without any downstream
consequences for accomplishing your
goals.
So, it doesn't actually change the way
that curiosity or information gain
enters the objective, but because of the
recursive belief updating, it kind of
contextualizes the info gain to be more
sensitive to downstream rewards. So, I
think that's a really powerful just like
algorithmic feature or computational
feature of sophisticated inference that
hopefully people will explore and can do
so now at scale with high throughput
with this um implementation.
Another big one is inductive inference.
So, this is a way that you can kind of
plan um for a goal future in the future
that's in the future by kind of planning
backwards. So, if you have some
transition tensor that has very
deterministic dynamics, you can kind of
use your knowledge of the dynamics and
the your knowledge of the goal state to
kind of prune the the originally
exponentially expansive search tree to
just a set of paths that um they you
know a priori
uh uh
have reachability between the goal and
your starting state. So, it's kind of
like um
uh
induction like the
dynamic programming. It's sort of this
the same principle where if you start
with the goal and then back propagate
the goal to to optimize your current
policy, it's that same principle, but
it's just using the the B tensor of your
active inference model to kind of
generate that
that inductive uh planning algorithm.
How it actually manifests in practice is
just an extra cost to your expected free
energy for policies. That's called an
inductive cost. So, it basically is a
cost that measures
um sure I could take this policy, but
how
how reachable is my final end state if I
were to take this policy. So, that
inductive cost kind of suppresses
policies that will bring you into parts
of the state space that are kind of like
um
uh sinks in the dynamics in the
transition dynamics of of the B matrix.
Um another big thing that's again
enabled by JAX is this um exact
filtering and smoothing in HMMs.
So, typically in active inference, we
use
message passing algorithms for the
hidden state inference step. So, things
like variational message passing,
marginal message passing,
belief propagation.
Um
but actually, there's nothing stopping
you from using better inference
algorithms for the hidden state
inference. So, what we did here is we
actually implemented exact inference on
HMMs. So, you actually don't need to use
an approximation for the inference if
you if the
generative model satisfies certain
properties. So, for instance, if the
generative model has a single hidden
state factor, you can actually do exact
inference on it.
And so, what we do is we we took an
inspiration from another JAX-based
package called DynaMax, which is for
fitting state space models in JAX.
And they have a really efficient um
associative scan-based algorithm for
fitting HMMs, both linear Gaussian HMMs
as well as discrete ones.
And so, we just basically took that and
and and did a more PyMDP-friendly
implementation of it and now are using
it here. The nice thing about
associative scan is it's actually
sublinear in time horizon. So, it kind
of does a quasi parallelization of the
treatment of time steps. Um
It's I think logarithmic in time. So,
the way it does this is it kind of takes
the associativity of the transition
operator as it operates on on a chain of
of time steps, and you can take
advantage of that to kind of divide the
full inference problem into a bunch of
subproblems that can be treated in
parallel. That's why it's like a
logarithmic in time because you're kind
of bisecting the sequence and then
bisecting the the subsequences. So, it
has this logarithmic scaling property.
Um so, that's also really nice and it
scales really nicely in long sequences.
So, you can do full filtering and
smoothing of your posterior states using
this associative scan.
Um despite that algorithm existing, we
still included the MMP and VMP
algorithms in the repo, but now they're
very highly optimized. They're much
faster
and they're fully differentiable, too.
So, you can pass gradients through them
and all that stuff.
Another big thing is this sparse
dependency structure. I think this was
also released in the last PMD P007, but
now it's actually just more flexible,
more fully integrated through the repo.
And what this means is you can kind of
specify the conditional dependency
structure of your generative model in a
much more um sparse way. So, for
instance, not all observation modalities
depend on all hidden state factors, and
you want to take advantage of that. In
the old PMD P and the old SPM, although
I think this is now also updated in SPM,
you would have to assume the kind of
naively that all hidden state factors
drive all observation modalities, and
what that in practice means is you just
have loads of redundant information in
your parameter tensors. But, if you know
that say only um the position
observation is driven by the position
hidden state, then you can make your
position observation no longer dependent
on the weather hidden state or some
other hidden state, and you can
basically chop off the dependency, and
the result is you get much smaller
parameter tensors.
So, now that's all integrated as well.
You can do it both for the A like the
hidden state to observation dependency.
You can also do it for hidden state at
time T to hidden state at time T plus
one dependency. So, multiple hidden
state factors can drive multiple other
hidden state factors. And then you can
also do this with action. So, action
control factors um typically just drive
a single hidden state factor, but now
with these B action dependencies, it's
another list of basically specifying the
dependency graph. You can have one
control factor drive multiple hidden
states or multiple control factors drive
one hidden state. So, all that
flexibility is now um built in. It It's
It was hard to engineer that in with all
the constraints of JAX, but we managed
to do it, so the inference is much
faster, and you're not wasting
computation.
Okay, so one I think of the most This
was actually one of the original
motivations for moving to the JAX back
end, and one of the most important
things for people working in cognitive
neuroscience and experimental psychology
is the idea of fitting PMD Ps to
behavioral data.
So, the the setting is kind of that you
have some participants in say a
psychology or psychophysics or cognitive
neuroscience study. They're taking
actions. You You're recording what
they're seeing say on like a screen or
some kind of stimulus setup, and you
want to describe their decisions as
being driven by an active inference
agent. So, this is like an inverse
problem of what are the parameters of an
active inference agent that best
describe the experimental decisions that
this person made.
And now we can do that very easily in
JAX. So, once we translated everything
to JAX, it made
putting PMD P active inference loops
into the forward model of the likelihood
model of a generative model of someone's
behavior very trivial. And this is
basically enabled by this package PyBa
Fit by Dimitri Markovik, which is really
nice cuz it allows you not [snorts] only
to use PMD P to fit uh the new JAX PMD P
to fit active inference models to
experimental data, but you can compare
it to other agent-based decision-making
models like reinforcement learning, for
instance, and variants of Bayesian or
non-Bayesian reinforcement learning.
So, here on the right, I just have a
very simple example of
using NUTS, which is the No-U-Turn
Sampler. It's like a very optimized way
of doing
um Hamiltonian Monte Carlo to infer the
parameter posteriors from a bunch of T
mazes, these classic agents
making decisions. So, the parameter that
we're inferring here is the agent's
beliefs about the reward probability
associated with choosing the correct
arm. Um so, that's like a classic thing
that kind of trades off the
explore-exploit dilemma for the T mazes
agent, and you can see by using NUTS
that you can basically recover uh
distributions over the parameter
posteriors that roughly track the true
reward probability. There's different
experimental setups where the
recoverability will be much better, but
this was something I whipped up probably
in 20 minutes and just ran it, and you
get a pretty nice correlation. So,
there's nice things like that um they
are now possible, and hopefully this is
going to be one of the things that will
actually allow people to start using PMD
P actually to fit experimental data.
Um the other nice thing about this is
because it's all backed by NumPyro, you
don't have to use HMC NUTS. You know,
for certain inference problems, you
might want to use
um stochastic variational inference or
black box variational inference to fit
it, or you might want to use the Laplace
method, like Laplace variational
inference. So, basically, there's a a
whole load of different
priors and inference algorithms and
parameterizations of those priors and
posteriors that you can use uh in in
NumPyro, and that's very nicely packaged
together in PyBa Fit. So, a lot of the
kind of low-level choices are abstracted
away from you by PyBa Fit, and you can
kind of try out different techniques for
fitting your your experimental data. You
don't need to commit to one particular
inference algorithm.
Um yeah, so another big thing is the new
documentation. So, the documentation now
includes way more examples than before.
Um so, there's a ton of new JAX-focused
notebooks that show different uses, all
those things I talked about,
sophisticated inference, inductive
inference,
um model fitting to behavioral data,
uh
just using sparse tensors. It's
something I didn't even talk about. You
can actually also do very
high-throughput computation by using
sparse tensors, which is something
supported by JAX.
Um there's now notebooks for all of
these things that you can access on the
docs, and after this I'll I'll just
quickly hop over to the docs to show
everyone that.
Um and then yeah, there's also going
back to the your simple grid world T
mazes,
all those like classic examples are
still included there. There's also a T
maze with distractors notebook that
explains the whole benefits of using
sophisticated inference.
And also the docs themselves just have a
better theme and kind of general
makeover compared to how they used to
be.
>> [gasps]
>> Um [clears throat] so, yeah, um I'll
pretty much close up with that. I guess
it's almost been an hour now. Um so,
yeah, uh links here. Here's the code.
The docs will We can hop over to that
after this. Release notes, and then if
there's any issues you ever have, feel
free to create an issue in PMD P. Just
added a little simulation of running a
bunch of agents in parallel using
inductive inference.
Um and I also want to acknowledge
There's a lot of people not on this list
who also worked and contributed to PMD
P, but just I wanted to highlight a few
key people, especially um Tim Ver Balen.
He put in a lot of effort into into
building PMD P. I want to acknowledge
his effort sophisticated inference,
battle testing PMD P in different
circumstances with his own use cases in
like robotics and various kind of more
high-dimensional specialized domains.
Um Dimitri Markovik, he was the one who
first convinced me and said we should do
this in JAX if you want to fit people's
behavior to it, and he was kind of the
main architect of a lot of the key
choices that went into the JAX back end.
So, I want to thank him a lot. I mean,
yeah, this basically wouldn't be
possible without him. I didn't even know
what JAX was when we first started
talking about this.
Um Reddy was also huge in developing the
um
sophisticated inference implementation
and also using active inference in PMD P
in
a lot of her own projects and just
adding new features, working on the
model compilation,
uh model description. Arun, who I think
is also here, was really great in
helping us organize the full um
uh 100 release
like
workflow and getting all the issues in
in play and also just keeping us on
track on on getting things and also
adding features as well, doing all of
that, CI features, also fundamental PMD
P features, doing an RGM implementation
as well. There's like a lot of really
good things, and and I'm really grateful
for that. And then there's just loads of
other people who have contributed
various things. I can't name everyone's
contribution,
but uh yeah, so I just want to
acknowledge that this was really a team
effort, and it was
it's a good expression of a lot of
people being interested in this
technology across a lot of disciplines.
Um yeah, so with that I'll end. I don't
know um Daniel, do you Should I first
hop to the docs, or do you want to have
some discussion first? I am pretty open
to whatever.
Yeah, how about um
meanwhile, anyone else can can add any
comments
or ask any questions to Connor, or just
bring up any points that weren't
covered,
and then we'll look at the docs, look at
some of the examples.
Yeah, sounds great.
Yeah, Peter
Yeah, Peter Yeah, Connor Connor, you can
call on here if you want.
You You're moderating.
Thanks, Connor. But, also by the way,
looking forward to seeing the docs, so
I'm also happy to wait till after that.
Uh
what do you think?
I have a
few questions, as you can probably
imagine.
Yeah, okay. Maybe Maybe we just quickly
go through the docs and do then do the
questions then. Yeah, I think that'll be
easier cuz it'll maybe then interrupt
the discussion. So, yeah, this is the
main documentation. It's still
uh like Read the Docs base, but now
using this MkDocs kind of thing, and I'm
using the Dracula theme. Might change
that at some point, but I kind of liked
the colors for now. So, this is the main
page.
Um there's a getting started tab over
here, installation. We're doing
everything through UV now, so that makes
things a lot easier. It's better than
pip in my experience.
There's a bunch of different dependency
groups, like if you're doing model
fitting, if you have a GPU on hand,
um if you want to mess with the docs or
run notebooks.
So, that that's pretty extensive.
Um see, there's also a JAX quick start
uh, that just shows you how to like run
something quickly in Jax. This is same
idea as what we used to have in NumPy,
but just now everything is more
uh, Jax friendly. A lot of these default
generation functions as well, they used
to be just uh, NumPy only right now Jax
based. So, ran generating random A
arrays, B arrays, uniform distributions,
stuff like that.
Um, there's a lot of different guides on
specific things. So, this rollout
function for the compiled agent
environment loops, um, this is really
nice uh, uh,
thing because of the throughput it gets
you and it's really nice uh, the API as
well. So, basically, once you've defined
your agent and your Jax JIT compatible
environment, you just pass the agent,
the environment into the rollout
function, set some time horizon, how
many steps you want to run, and then RNG
key, so a random key to seed the
randomness.
And then what you'll get is the
trajectory of the agent states over the
history of the rollout, so their
beliefs, actions, observations, uh,
posteriors over policies, as well as
like the final state of the agent and
any other like relevant info. Um,
so I find that really nice.
Um, yeah, so that's just a guide about
how to use that uh,
and as I said um, before the agent and
invent and are both natively batched.
So, if you just add a leading dimension
to your agent or to your environments,
you can just easily run multiple agents
and multiple environments in parallel.
One agent for
every environment or one environment
with 50 different agents, you can do all
of that with this rollout thing.
Um, yeah, there's just kind of new uh,
building blocks for envs themselves, how
you make the environments, how you
instantiate them.
Um, there's yeah, actually one thing
that I didn't mention, there's this new
PyMDP env structure. So, now you can
make an environment and initialize it
with the same parameters that you used
to initialize the agent. So, you can
basically make an environment using the
A, B, and D tensors you used to generate
the agent.
And then you'll basically have an
isomorphism between the generative
process and the generative model. So,
that's a good way to kind of test out
uh, what assumptions can be broken on
the environment side without
compromising performance on the agent
side. So, that's kind of this ideal
situation. But, of course, you can also
run
any arbitrary environments with a PyMDP
agent. They don't need to be structured
this way. It's just a kind of a special
case.
This is uh, there's just a a classic
tutorial on how to think about
generative models, hidden state factors,
and modalities.
Oh, yeah, and then there's the kind of
um, tutorials. So, we have this notebook
gallery now that has subsections for the
different tutorials. So, there's like
kind of a getting started subset, which
includes
how to build generative models with this
new model construction API, so the model
description dict and all that stuff.
So, this is showing how you would build
this thing with like strings and then
populate it with uh, probabilities. And
then finally, once you have the actual
model, you can create an agent with it
and then start running things with
rollout or with with whatever you want.
Um, T maze demo, T maze with
distractors, that's this one where
there's like some sources of information
that are irrelevant to the task, some
that are.
Um,
graph worlds, yeah, there's there's all
sorts of things. Uh,
there's a a whole set of notebooks just
on sophisticated inference and
highlighting its different advantages
under different um, settings. So, like
in the T maze, the T maze with
distractors, on a graph worlds where an
agent is navigating a a gen a
like a world that's structured like a
graph, so some nodes are reachable from
others.
Two on inductive inference, um, learning
parameters, so updating the A and B
matrices from data. So, that's done on a
grid world example.
Maybe also fit uh, highlight the pipe of
fit one. So, this is the one I I
described before where you're basically
uh, creating a T maze agent in a
generative model, sampling the behavior
of that T maze agent.
So, for instance, here I was sampling
looks like uh,
10 different agents.
And then using those 10 agents and
fitting their posterior uh, parameters
with nuts,
um, the HMC, or fitting it with
in just a couple lines you can, so
that's fitting it with nuts or that you
can switch to a different inference
algorithm like black box variation
variational inference and it's the same
uh, same idea. You can basically use
different inference algorithms to fit
your your models uh, to experimental
data, which is really nice. And this is
all made super easy with this pipe of
fit package. So, you have different kind
of wrappers on nuts and SVI and
different uh, inference algorithms.
Um,
oh, yeah, here's a kind of a cool one is
uh, using PyMDP together with a neural
encoder. So, this is training a very
small MLP to embed um, continuous
observations into the discrete
observation space of a uh, a PyMDP
agent. So, this is an example right here
on the left, an agent is seeing
basically continuous 2D observations
from these Gaussian clusters, but it's
learning end to end to map those
continuous 2D observations to discrete
states. And then it's doing planning in
the that discrete state space to say go
from
mode one to mode two, three, four, five.
So, this is just a demonstration of how
you can basically train PyMDP agents end
to end to map from continuous
observations into a discrete space on
which they can do all the message
passing and planning.
Um, so that was just one very
yeah, this is an example of showing the
agent um, doing the same planning, but
now what I'm plotting here are the
decision boundaries of the MLP, the
multi-layer perceptron that was trained
as a front end. So, you can see
basically that the MLP is learning to
partition the space into these discrete
states that the agent can then do
planning on.
Um, yeah, but there's these are very
elementary, I would say, demonstrations
of the full capabilities. I feel like
there's a lot more people can do with
the whole differentiability side of
things.
Um,
yeah, I think I'll I'll I'll end there.
If anyone wants to dive into a
particular notebook, I'm happy to do
that as well.
Maybe Pedro, we can come back to you
now.
Okay. Um, I'm just looking at my So,
thank you, Connor.
It's very exciting. Congratulations. The
whole field has been waiting for this
for a while and and there's joy in the
streets and it's an inspiration.
>> Thanks.
Good to see.
>> [laughter]
>> And well, thank you to the rest of the
people who worked on this. So, I see
Dimitri and Aaron and some other people.
And um,
I was just as a note, as you know, I'm
working on the Julia version, which kind
of looks up to PyMDP as its big brother.
So, that's it's very nice and a lot of
the
exciting points you brought up are
exactly the
the some of our goals, right? So, we're
So, thanks for the inspiration on that
point as well.
Um,
>> Yeah, definitely. I just but sorry to
interrupt you. I This is one thing I
actually want to do is to also benchmark
it against active inference.jl and
rxinfer, but I just didn't have time, to
be honest. But, I I yeah, that that
would be really cool to do as well cuz I
know Julia is incredibly fast, too, and
has the JIT stuff kind of built in.
So, we are
we are moving towards the new release.
When that's done, I think it would be
nice to do. Maybe we can do that
together.
Yeah, yeah.
Um,
but enough talk about my own package,
that that's not the point right now. I
suppose.
Um,
so maybe So, one question I had was
because um, my only worry personally
with Jax has been that it's harder to go
and
and poke
as a not master expert level developer
behind the package. So, let's say I want
to add a different parameter learning
function instead of
uh, the Ryan Smith style and I want to
have a different parameterization. I
want to throw in a a Gaussian filter to
do it or something like that.
How easy is it to go and change kind of
the internals in that way? Is it Can Can
I just plug in a function for that? Is
that a plan? What do you think? Yeah,
that's a good question. So, I would say
that I see I saw there's two ends on the
on the it's harder as an entry point for
sure on the functional programming side
of things. Like you're forced to code
functionally, so you
have to s- um,
kind of do away with these assumptions
of storing state on objects, like on as
properties and attributes of a class,
right? It's a lot more You can of course
have PyTrees that have properties, but
it's a lot more instantiating a new
instance of a class or a PyTree every
time you want to change something. So,
that takes some getting used to. And
also passing keys everywhere.
On the other hand, I think the way we
wrote it is actually incredibly amenable
to this modular, I want to go in and add
a new thing approach. So, this is one of
the things I had to deal with when
adding the associative scan based
inference cuz now I was adding a new new
inference algorithm next to VMP and MMP.
I think we've written it in a way that
actually makes it easy specifically
because of the V mapping aspect across
agents. So, when you're thinking of your
algorithm, you don't have to immediately
imagine, oh, how's this going to
broadcast against like a thousand
agents? As long as you write it
according to the Jax convention, so
functional,
uh, no in place updates, um, keeping
dtypes and shapes static between input
and output, again, that is a constraint,
and passing in an RNG key if you need
randomness anywhere. As long as you obey
those constraints, you can basically
just write a new function, add it to
inference.py, which is still one of the
libraries that handles inference,
um, or algos.py if it's an inference
algorithm or learning.py if it's a new
learning algorithm. And then that can
get and then you would also have to add
some kind of um
learning you would have to go into the
update parameters method of the agent
and say,
you know, if if I want to use this
algorithm then I'm going to dispatch to
this learning.py function. So that kind
of still that structure that was in the
NumPy version where there's agent
methods and those agent methods then
call and import functions from the sub
sub libraries and then call those rather
than define all the all the math and
computation in the agent class. That
structure still remains. So you still
have that modularity.
Um
yeah. I have a question um
on that cuz I think it might be nice for
the tutorial on
I want PiMDP but with this other
parameter learning function or something
or with this other planning
model or
with this other
variant of expected free energy as loss
function or something like that.
It's just a thought.
Yeah, there So in this validating
sophisticated inference I believe that
there is
a for specifically for this one case of
switching between vanilla planning and
and sophisticated planning I think there
is an example that shows you how to
easily toggle between the two.
And for the inference algorithms
maybe in this one there is.
Or I mean if you want to add one I
guess.
Yeah, yeah. I can comment on that. So
I'm actually at the moment halfway
through trying to get the renormalized
generative model
stuff into a notebook
and the active parameter learning is
something that we don't currently have a
good implementation of in PiMDP itself.
So Carl has done some
very specific stuff with that. So
my first attempt at this is going to be
have that defined in the notebook
effectively as like a little module that
we can like PiMDP agent plus this new
learning algorithm this is how you would
do that. But my long term goal is once
it's actually there to then put it in
the main thing. So
I think that modularity of it works
quite nicely. I will like we'll chat
with the rest of the team on
how much of the stuff we want to support
ourselves as part of the PiMDP API. So
like once cuz once an algorithm is there
we want everyone to use it and rely on
it and that it's not going to just
disappear. So that nuisance burden is
something that we need to be careful of
because this field is moving so quickly.
If we put every single new algorithm in
this then it's going to explode. But if
we focus on the modularity then you can
have the core we maintain the core as
like almost like a standard library and
then everyone else can bring their own
implementations if they so wish. And I
think that's quite a nice sweet spot to
be on in terms of us providing the
infrastructure for doing active
inference. But it allows particularly
like users who are going to range quite
widely from
you know sort of PhD students who are
doing they want to
simulate an agent that's
doing you know some sort of cognitive
psychology experiment and you know it's
maybe it's small scale but you know
they're trying to show an interesting
problem or maybe this disease affects
this type of planning or parameter
estimation etc. Compared to somebody
who's like I want an active inference
classifier that's like I don't care how
the brain works I just want this to run
at some speed on production.
Um because we want to support a huge
range of users it's better that we just
provide the skeleton and then everyone
else provides what they need in order to
achieve their goal. Um so the modularity
is absolutely key for that.
Um but yeah the more we can show people
how to use that the better. So uh yeah
watch this space basically.
I think there are exactly three groups
of people active inference caters to one
is the AI people who just want it to
run.
One is the theoretical people who want
to simulate some proof of principle of
for what some
and then there's the applied modelers
who want to fit it to behavioral data.
And you're right that the
the needs of those three groups are
different.
So it's so yeah.
We had the same design philosophy of
like
build the skeleton make it very easy to
plug in a user made bit or switch out
bits and pieces and then
the standard ones
put them as a standard library where you
can get them from something like that. I
think that's
something nice.
Um
on that on that note of like the
modularity. So one of the things we've
discussed I think in an issue somewhere
but it's not currently implemented is
the idea of
instead of
having like flags in the agent class
um that are saying oh am I use MMP or
VMP or exact
as you add more and more algorithms
that's going to be really ugly cuz
you're just going to have like flags for
every sub case. So one of the things
that we started to explore also with
this rollout function is the idea of
either passing in something like an
inference configuration
that could be basically the parameters
for some callable that does your hidden
state inference and then that way you
can just pass both the call like a a
pointer to the callable in from outside
like my my favorite inference algorithm
and then the parameters like the
configuration to that and then when you
get to that
inference step which like you said Arun
is just kind of the the skeleton
infrastructure that we provide then your
particular JAX compatible callable gets
used to actually perform the hidden
state inference. And so we kind of have
that with this idea. So for when you're
using the rollout the policy search
argument is sort of exactly that idea.
You actually just pass in
a callable which is some custom policy
search routine. So you don't have to use
the exhaustive tree search you don't
have to use a sophisticated inference
you could actually pass in your own
domain specific or custom
policy search function. So there is a
world where we just expand that sort of
pattern to inference learning all these
different
sub models.
Maybe also exciting to talk because we
were trying to do that with the Julia
package and it might be nice to align
that a bit like cuz I think even the I
suppose if
if you took that far enough it would
mean that you could use much of your
skeleton with an entirely different type
of generative model.
Yeah. As long as you have an inference
procedure that works with it right?
Even a sampler or something like that.
Yeah definitely.
Cuz then you can do maybe continuous
state space
stuff as long as you have some inference
that works for it.
I don't know. Want to share my
excitement maybe about that
idea. Yeah, yeah. That's something I've
thought about as well. It's like cuz you
could just yeah the the big problem with
the continuous state space as you know
is that defining the expected free
energy is a bit trickier.
So you need to use probably sampling to
ex compute those information gains.
If you say have a Gaussian mixture
likelihood or like a Gaussian likelihood
where you have one Gaussian component
per hidden state then to evaluate the
info gain of those rollouts you need to
use some kind of sampling or
approximation. But if you if you make
everything really
high level and abstract then there's
nothing stopping you from doing that. So
just in your policy search function you
have some step that computes a bunch of
samples to compute some you know
conditional entropies or whatever.
Exciting.
So I have other questions but maybe I'll
for a moment if
all of you or Dimitri or Arun had your
hand raised earlier and stuff.
I did have a question for you Connor
which is so
first of all I'll say congratulations on
getting us to V1. That's huge.
What do you think is missing for future
releases? What are you excited to work
on?
Yeah that's a great question.
Yeah there's there's there's various
one-off features that we just don't have
like these things with sampling
based schemes for estimating info gains
in continuous spaces.
So that I think would be the biggest
thing is getting the continuous
distribution front end in there.
So yeah this I mean this I've gone back
and forth on this because sometimes I
think to myself it's a bit out of scope
for PiMDP. PiMDP is very kind of wedded
to the SPM inspired discrete state space
models only. But one of the biggest
blockers for people actually using PiMDP
is the fact the scalability issues. Like
I'm not I'm not going to encode my image
in a bunch of discrete one hot vectors.
I mean the RGM thing is like one
solution to that but another solution is
you just have more flexible
distributions over your input variables.
So part of me is like maybe that's the
burden for another package and then you
can just tie up your like something like
RXInfer which does deal with continuous
distributions right? It deals with all
basically conjugate exponential family
and I guess more now.
So you could just link deal with that
for continuous stuff and deal with PiMDP
for discrete planning. But I also would
just be personally excited to work on
that because I think it would be really
cool to have PiMDP agents that can do
planning in like a Gaussian space. You
can kind of now do that because of the
modularity and because of the
differentiability. So you could hook up
instead of a neural network as this
front end I was hearing you could hook
up say a backward message from a
Gaussian distribution right? There's
nothing really stopping you from already
hooking up continuous stuff. So anyway
but I think that would be a big one to
work on.
Another one would be just to rigorously
characterize and optimize not the
sophisticated inference implementation
which is really good but also all the
hyper parameters. The sophisticated
inference has loads and loads of hyper
parameters which I don't fully
understand and I think even the
developers of sophisticated inference
still don't know the the space of hyper
parameters that gives you good
performance of sophisticated inference
in particular regimes. So, that's
something that I want to get better
characterization of. So, maybe some way
of given a planning problem in a
generative model, automatically
determining the best hyper parameter set
for
uh sophisticated inference.
Um another thing I think would be really
cool would to be I don't know. This is
more for pedagogy and like interactive
visualization, but some kind of like
POMDP server where you can actually
that's like hosting inference and
visualization. So, you can like upload
like an environment or an agent
configuration and then get in real time
like an interactive visualization uh of
your agent
um
interacting in that environment. Just as
an intuition pump for people who want to
say, "Okay, what if I change this? What
if I change this?"
That would break the ability to jit the
entire interaction loop because you'd be
a human human user giving input into the
system, but you could still get the
single time step rendering incredibly
fast because of how efficient POMDP is.
So, that would be cool, but that would
also require some resources for actually
hosting inference on some kind of
server.
Um yeah.
Can I just come in with on a couple of
those? So, I think um yeah, your your
first point on
just the flexibility of inputs that we
can give to a POMDP P agent is
exactly that, right? Like the more the
wider that scope, the more users we can
we can help. Uh I think that's that's a
really good point. Whether this should
be a separate package or in POMDP, a
nice middle ground might just be
notebooks. Just show, "This is how you
can do it."
But we don't necessarily have to support
that in perpetuity. And I think that's a
really good nice way of just basically
having
a garden with a thousand flowers bloom,
and then we can see what the community
uses, and if we then think, "Okay, this
is something that everybody wants to
use, and we are happy to support it,
happy to maintain it." Then we can shift
that into standard POMDP, but we don't
have to.
Um
I think that's one thing that I'm really
excited for for the next I'd say like 12
months, 24 months, is to see how people
use what we currently have.
Yeah. Looking at the issues that are
raised, what are people requesting, what
are people what are people not using,
and then going, "Right, okay, we can
either break and change deprecate some
stuff, but also like if there's stuff
that's really important that people
really value, then we can support that
and maintain that and make sure that
everybody's working from like a standard
base. And then that makes it much easier
for somebody like a PhD student who
doesn't have a lot of training to just
get up and running quickly, or software
engineer who doesn't necessarily
understand all of the maths behind
active inference to go, "Yeah, okay, I
can just use sophisticated inference out
of the box with sensible defaults." And
as you say, the hyper parameter space
already having been somewhat tuned
to get at least decent performance, if
not optimal performance across all
regimes.
Uh that does lead onto the second point
on the hyper parameter stuff. This is
something that also, I'll be honest,
highly confuses me.
>> [laughter]
>> Um
It's an absolute zoo of etas and Greek
letters just going, "Yeah, this is 512.
Deal with it." Yeah.
And I think that's I whenever I have
like sort of
sort of prodded um the people who know
better than me about this, uh the answer
I tend to get is, "Oh yeah, just wrap it
in a loop, cook uh calculate your
negative free energy over your hyper
parameter space, and then you just pick
the best one, right?"
>> Mhm. And that is both
I think a good answer and a bad answer
because that's a lot of work for a user
to do. Expensive, yeah. And it's
expensive. I think POMDP getting as
efficient as it is gets you closer to
being able to do that without having to
go, "Right, I have my very toy example.
Let me set a CPU running for 2 weeks,
and I'll come back later."
Now we're actually getting closer to
that, but I still think it would be nice
to have
I don't know, informed priors maybe on
these hyper parameters a bit like I
think that there are going to be some
things where you're like, "You shouldn't
set this value to this." Or Yeah. if you
or if you're like if you have these
values, you are in this regime of this
type of agent. Yeah.
>> That sort of guidance in the docs could
probably get you 80% of the value for
20% of the effort without having to just
do exhaustive searching over a hyper
parameter space that you don't really
fully understand.
Yeah, absolutely. There there there I
think there's a lot that can't actually
be done a priori without actually having
to run those sweeps. Like for instance,
certain thresholds on when do you prune
branches, or when do you ignore certain
um branches in the planning tree because
the observation uh probability of those
particular modalities has dropped below
some threshold. A lot of that I think
can at least be approximated a priori
just given the structure of your A and B
tensors. So, like your B tensor kind of
sets some rate on the diffusion of
future probability, right? Like you can
just estimate that by just taking like
an exponential of the B matrix X steps
in the future, given some planning
horizon, and some B matrix, you can
basically estimate when certain noises
will drop below some threshold. And then
you could probably use that just at
least put yourself in the right range
for those hyper parameters.
Um so yeah, I I totally agree, and I
think there's actually pretty concrete
ways you could start to do that.
Yeah, Peter.
I I presume we have to stop in 10
minutes, right?
Oh yeah, that's right. It's uh 6:20. I
can stay a little longer, but yeah. Um
so maybe because I I have many
things to mention now, one tiny thing,
Dimitri.
So, I'm also making basically Julia
version of PyBefit.
And so maybe that's a good reason to
chat at some point, Dimitri.
Yes, and that would be great. I mean, I
I wanted to thank Connor for promoting
PyBefit.
And also to announce that
a place for a maintainer of the package
is open, right?
>> [laughter]
>> So, I don't want to like be that person
in the future, so
I I mean, I I haven't used it in a
while, and
it's probably right for some
improvements.
Um but yeah, uh
Uh that that's yeah, the state. So, I'm
also not that much in the field of
cognitive experimental cognitive
neuroscience anymore, so
Cognitive modeling is is the Exactly.
Whoever wants to use it should also
apply to for a maintainer position.
But And I I have to jump now, so sorry.
Uh yeah, but yeah, just write me an
email, Peter, and we can chat from now.
Okay. Yeah. Uh you got time. Thank you.
I'll see you around.
Thanks, Connor.
No. Um so maybe I'll I'll happen pinging
Dimitri,
and I'll I know Tanner has his hand
raised. And I was just thinking that
maybe because there's a lot of these
things like you said, the continuous
state space models, Connor,
we want to do, and we might use RXN
first as back end
for them, for example. But also the
discussions on the planning stuff and
hyper parameter like we're trying to
separate that into
what are really parameters of how to
prune a tree search, and what are
parameters of how to do
sophisticated inference, right? You can
you could do sophisticated inference not
in a tree search way, and you would need
that if you have a continuous action
space or continuous observation space
and stuff.
Mhm. I just had the thought, I don't
know if it's a good one,
but maybe it would be nice to do like a
regular
monthly active inference software
development
experience sharing meeting or something
like that. Mhm. Yeah.
Because I I think there's a lot to talk
about, and uh
I'm sure we have a lot to learn from
you, but but maybe the other way around,
and there's also the CPP people and the
SPM people.
>> [snorts]
>> I'm sure maybe I'm sure Carl would be
kind of we could even [clears throat]
make it a TMB
uh thing. All right, yeah.
Yeah, I'm definitely open to that. I
think that's a great idea.
Because I think one thing is to learn
from each other, and another thing is to
align the software tools a bit so that
they
use the same terminology, have the same
kind of document examples, um
link to each other, set up a shared
testing workflow where we make sure that
they do the same thing, for example.
These kind of things.
>> Yeah, validation, yeah, for sure.
So, I just wanted to put that out there
at least, and then I'll save the rest of
my list of questions for maybe for those
moments.
Yeah, that sounds like a great idea.
I mean, I know everyone's time is
limited,
right? So,
not intending to
grab time, but I just thought
maybe that would be useful.
Yeah, I'm definitely down with that.
Um I don't know who is next. Does anyone
know what the order
I'll just briefly ask the questions from
the live chat, and uh so, first question
was from Andrew Bashier asking about
basically what kinds of contributions
and how to um
offer contributions.
And then Ted VR asked about any advice
on updating old code from legacy POMDP.
Mhm. Both great questions.
Um so yeah, for the first one, the the
usual workflow is basically
uh GitHub issues. So, you raise an issue
if there's a problem like a bug.
And if you want to contribute to fixing
that bug, then that's just basically a
matter of having an open discussion in
one of those issues. So, this is kind of
how we did the 1.0.0 release. I don't
know if Rune if we ever had even like a
a meeting. We basically were just
asynchronously talking through GitHub.
So, GitHub issues is is one way just to
report specific like features, bug
fixes, things that you want to see
implemented, you want to implement
yourself.
Another way is um through discussions.
So, this is kind of how we
uh did the organization of the um 1.0.0
release. I think I closed that
discussion now, but basically we had a
discussion thread opened here where we
were
uh discussing how to go forward. So, you
could also start a discussion.
Um and in terms of like concrete like
how to contribute, I mean the the
easiest way is you fork the repo, like
the concrete way is you fork the repo,
and you open a pull request to um to
main. And then we you tag me or someone
else uh on the developer team uh as a
reviewer. Arun, for instance, is pretty
um good with with responding to reviews.
Thank you, Arun. And uh and then we'll
get we'll get uh reviewing it. Um in
terms of like coding conventions and
stuff, I haven't been that We haven't
been that like
um
rigorous, I would say, or or uh
standardized with like how to
particularly do a contribution, but just
pull request,
informative description in the pull
request, make sure the CI passes so like
the unit tests and stuff.
Um and then there's a bunch of automatic
stuff. Like, there's a linter, there's a
pre-commit hooks for the um
cleaning up the Jupyter notebook. So, a
lot of that stuff is kind of handled for
you.
Um and then the second question was
about Oh, yeah, the uh migration guide.
Yeah.
That's a great point. So, we have this
whole tutorial here. Think you can see
it on the screen
that is uh about exactly that question.
Like, if I used to have a bunch of code
in NumPy, how do I migrate it to JAX?
And if there's any feedback on this, if
like it's not clear like, "Oh, how do I
migrate this thing? This isn't covered
in the guide." Please raise an issue or
raise a discussion um and then we can
get that in there.
Uh but yeah, so basically it's it's
stepping through and describing all
these things I briefly mentioned in the
talk, which is
the kind of old NumPy version versus the
new JAX version columns, and then how to
actually do that, how to deal with the
new batch size parameter, which can be a
bit unintuitive at first.
Um yeah, so that that should hopefully
help with all those migration uh issues.
Uh whilst we quickly have time, can I
come in on the contribution uh aspect of
this? Yeah, yeah, go for it. Um I think
in this day and age it's worth
highlighting at the moment. First of
all, like everyone who's working on this
is doing this out of volunteering time,
their own free time. No one is being
paid for any of this. So, this is all
out of because we are interested and we
care and uh we want to be part of the
community and we want to contribute to
the community.
Uh it is very exciting if other people
want to also contribute to this as well,
and we welcome that. I would caution
though, please do not just get your
large language model Claude code coding
agent to just look at the pymdp repo,
generate issues, generate require pull
requests, all of this sort of stuff. Uh
I am very aware that already active
inference is a very difficult thing to
understand. There is enough cognitive
debt of people understanding what their
code is doing.
I do not want to put large language
models in the mix without very careful
control on what the code is doing. Um
and yeah, we're all doing this because
we're interested and we also want to
learn and we also want to understand
what the stuff is doing. Um so, please
if you are going to contribute, um by
all means use co- large language model
coding tools if you would like,
but use your brain first and foremost is
my general plea to the community. And if
we get just clearly, you know,
automated automatic AI slop, we will
reject it immediately.
But like, you know, a good a good pull
request is on
Sorry, I actually myself
A good pull request is something that a
human being can easily understand. So,
you know, like if it's 20,000 lines and
we can't tell what's going on, obviously
we're not going to accept that. So,
general best practices of software
engineering, please do apply. Small,
dedicated pull requests that do a one
clearly defined thing, one demonstrable
thing, ideally coming with unit tests as
well.
We love to see it.
Yeah, thanks, Arun.
Any last comments anyone wants to make?
Otherwise, this is um the tip of the
iceberg of the tip of the iceberg
because it's such a powerful
methodological advance.
And maybe we'll be able to revisit in
sort of scheduled meetings or in future
model streams like
a little bit of a review
example highlighting
different kinds of contributions that
people are making, different benchmarks.
There's just so many ways to to go with
it.
And um
if anyone has any extra or last comments
for this one,
please go for it.
Uh yeah, I just I I wanted to say thank
you, Daniel, for inviting me to um come
give this presentation. I really
appreciate it. Um and also thanks to
everyone who uh contributed to the
discussion and again to all the
developers of pymdp. It was really
pleasure to build this and now get the
chance to kind of
unveil it to the world to everyone here.
So, thanks.
Great. All right.
Good work. Till next time.
Thanks, everyone. Take care.